Welcome to Ear Biscuits.
The podcast where two lifelong friends
talk about life for a long time.
I'm Link.
And I'm Rhett.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting
we're going to do something
that we haven't done in a while.
And we're gonna go down the rabbit hole.
Yes, yes.
This is when we take like a subject, topic
and we've brought nothing,
we've brought nothing
except ourselves into this.
Nothing.
And no holds barred we are
going deep into the rabbit hole
based on a topic that is generated.
Let's link arms and dive in.
We're not going yet.
I'm already gone.
Well I'll join you in the
rabbit hole in a second.
This is the last time that I will say
something about your glasses.
These are my anything go glasses.
But I just, you know,
you've made this decision.
I am coming to terms with it.
You can do whatever you want.
It's your face.
But I am looking at it.
Yeah.
I think, I do.
They're just glasses.
I think they're cool.
I think they're cool glasses.
Thank you, man.
It's got, you know, you got good
you made a good fashion choice.
As the wise philosopher once said
"Can't nobody tell me nothing."
Okay, I don't know who that was.
The wise philosopher.
Just the last thing I'll say is that
there are gonna be people
who stumble upon this video
and other subsequent videos in
which you wear these glasses
and they will come to conclusions that you
then may have to either confirm or deny
or steer them away from.
If people want me to rest as anything.
Can I put 'em on for a second?
Anything in there. Yeah man.
Let me just put 'em on for a second.
Yeah, you'll see what's up.
Just so.
You'll see what's up. They're light.
I'm just saying.
That's cool, man.
All I'm just saying is that,
first of all, I can't see.
Now I know what's happened.
Your left eye is not great,
your right eye's okay.
I've beat you to it.
That's what you're saying.
You can't wear these glasses.
Well, no, no, I'm not
gonna wear these glasses.
In fact, I keep thinking I'm
gonna have to get glasses
and my vision just keeps going, so.
I think those look just
bomb ass on you, man.
Right.
It's too bad they're mine.
They do. My question is,
if I wore these glasses
what would you say to me
if I was the one who had
worn these glasses first?
Because, let's be honest
you're definitely the
one who points things out
on people a lot more than I do.
Right, right, right,
let me, give me a few.
Fashion decisions.
Hey, gimme some time to
think about your question
so I can come up with an answer.
The exact same thing you're saying to me.
Gimme my glasses back.
But people are drawing
conclusions about me now.
What conclusions are they drawing?
That guy's got some bomb ass taste, man.
I mean, some people might be saying that.
And he got some balls to back it up too.
Hmm. Do you think a guy rides
a loud motorcycle's got big balls?
Usually, I think it's
compensating for something.
I like the way these glasses look.
I like the way these glasses feel.
I like the way these glasses
make me feel about myself.
You don't have to defend
the choice of glasses.
Oh, I'm not defending it.
I made that clear.
I am establishing it.
I told you, this is the last time
I'm ever gonna talk about 'em.
You should get some, man.
You know what? I'll get you a pair.
I'm gonna get sunglasses
that you can't see my eyes.
What are you gonna do about that?
See, you can see my eyes
that's the great thing about 'em.
Yeah, you can from some angles.
There's a video version of
this show over on YouTube
if you're only listening
to this you can wait
you can wait six days. You can watch it
on the Ear Biscuits YouTube channel.
You can watch me from behind my glasses.
We've heard that the young
kids, they prefer to watch.
They will not, are we right about this?
We've been told that the young people
have to see who's talking.
I mean.
Or else I guess they just
don't know who's talking.
I don't understand it, because.
All the podcasts on Spotify
are gonna be pushing for video.
That's what I'm hearing here.
But do you watch?
No.
I do things while listening to podcasts.
I'm driving, I'm working out, I'm walking.
I walked last night.
I didn't listen to a podcast,
I listened to a book, but.
Cool.
I don't understand.
What are they doing
while they're watching?
I drive, I bike, I
don't watch people talk.
What are they doing
while they're watching?
What are they doing?
Getting another layer of, I mean
we're kind of proving
their point right now.
Another layer of entertainment.
What are they doing right now?
'Cause they're not just
listening or watching a podcast.
They're also, "I'm also studying."
You can't do both of
those at the same time.
If you're trying to do your homework
and you've got this on in the background.
First of all, you know what?
Yeah, you should do that.
I have split interests here.
Yeah.
Because I want people to
watch. We need the views.
But your education is important.
You've gotta focus on
your freaking schoolwork.
No, you've gotta develop.
Reward yourself.
Develop the ability to do what I can't
which is two things at once.
Listen to a podcast and study.
Use different parts of your brain.
Like, divide it up. Do it.
I don't think anybody can do that.
Do it. So, how do you wanna do this?
Hey, hey, hey, don't touch my computer.
How do you wanna do this?
I can't let go now.
Well, we used to do a thing
where like there would be
something written on a
envelope and we'd open it up.
But that was just a waste of paper.
So, I've gone to conversationStarters.com.
Oh, it looks like a great website.
It's great graphic design
at the top especially.
ConversationStarters.com.
Is this like, you're really
apprehensive on your first date
and you've got conversationstarters.com
down there below the table at Chili's
and you're kinda looking down.
Yeah, right.
"Like, what are you looking at?"
"Oh, just."
Oh nothing. Just seeing what time it was.
It's time for me to start
another conversation.
Completely unrelated to the previous one.
I also, just so you know.
Oh man. I'm having so much fun already.
I also.
It's probably the glasses.
Well, I was going to
capitalizemytitle.com.
What?
Because when you search
random topic generator or topic generator
capitalize my title.
What is that?
Is the first one that comes up
but I don't even understand.
Like if I were to go to what it is, just.
What?
Dude, that's an ad. X out of the ad.
Do I need to teach you how
to browse the internet?
But why is? No. But why is capitalize my?
I clicked on the homepage.
So now I'm at capitalizemytitle.com.
And it just says, "Making
title capitalization easy.
Automatically capitalize and
case convert to title case."
Oh. I. Yeah that's great.
When you're just writing
stuff out in all a lower case
and then you've gotta like.
And you have a really long
title that you can't just edit.
This is like a subtitle. You've
gotta subtitle that also.
But there's lots of ads on it.
I hate having to capitalize
every word in a title.
It's exhausting.
But if I could just
paste it into a website
and then it spits it out
and then I paste that.
That's a lot.
Well.
A lot easier.
Now you can do that at
capitalizemytitle.com.
You could also get some
Nikes based on the ads.
Two Nike ads.
Go to random generator.
So.
But I am gonna use that
capitalizemytitle.com.
But I'm going to conversationstarters.com.
Conversationstarters.com.
I like the vibe.
The big brother to capitalizemytitle.com.
Okay. I'm gonna generate a topic.
Generate a topic.
Now we're not gonna start
talking about this topic
unless we both agree that this
is something worth talking about.
But when we do, my vote
is you just keep talking
and you see where the rabbit hole goes.
And if you get to the
bottom of that rabbit hole
maybe you start a new conversation.
Mhmm.
But.
Maybe you curl up and die.
What is the biggest priority
in your life right now?
Oh gosh, seriously?
No, no, no.
What's the biggest priority
in my life right now?
Don't answer it. Don't even
begin talking about it.
It's a dumb question.
Yeah.
What is your favorite dessert?
Who do you think we are?
What's your favorite dessert?
A couple of guys who eat
food on the internet?
Conversationstarters.com
don't ask that question
on a date because what if they don't have
the dessert at the restaurant?
What if Chili's doesn't
serve that dessert?
Right.
What is this, a AMA comprised
of only middle schoolers?
"What's your favorite dessert?"
What did you do on your
most recent birthday?
Man, I don't remember.
Poolside.
Yeah, I do. Did I talk
about it here already?
Yeah, kind of.
We probably already talked about that.
What is the first thing
you do in the morning?
I don't wanna talk to you about that.
God this site sucks, man.
Do you recycle?
All right, let's talk about this, man.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Do you recycle?
I think this is a great opportunity for us
to talk about things that
we don't really understand.
Which is my favorite stuff to talk about.
'Cause I have feelings about this
because we just received
something on our trash can.
Yep.
Did you receive it as well?
Yeah, a bucket.
Did you get a bucket on top?
You've got a freaking bucket
on top of your trash can.
Yeah, they're doing this in Los Angeles?
But then, I think this is a good thing.
Yes.
This is a good thing,
dude. Why are you angry?
So, there's. I don't
know how to use it yet.
I think it's a scam.
So it must be an LA county thing.
Had a ring at the doorbell.
I go up to the door and I open it, and.
You had a doorbell ring?
And down there, like in the middle.
Not right at the door.
Even further out than where
they would normally drop a package.
Package droppers are pretty
good about putting it
behind the flower pots
and stuff like that.
Getting it close.
So it won't get stolen.
Yeah.
This bucket. And I would
say it was kind of squarish.
Probably 10 inches square.
14 inches tall.
14 inches tall. It's a pail. It's got a.
I think it has a handle and it has a lid.
It does.
Squarish. It has like stickers around it.
Did you read the instructions?
Not yet.
Oh, I did. Me and Jesse had
a whole conversation about this thing.
I keep meaning to but I was like
I'm not ready for this burden.
Well, I'm about to blow your mind.
So it's a compost bucket where the.
I wouldn't call it a compost bucket.
That would be an overstatement.
It's a plastic bucket.
I would call it a bucket.
Made of plastic.
That is for food waste.
And you're supposed to
put your food waste in it
because, as we know.
The pigs need to eat it.
But because if you start
putting a bunch of food waste
in the landfill, it creates methane.
Methane.
It's not good for the environment, so.
Whereas if you did the
right thing with food waste
you can turn it into soil.
There's actually products.
I know of at least one product
out there that you can,
you can get like a highfalutin
machine that will turn.
Yeah. It was a sponsor of ours.
Yeah. I don't know if
it's out yet, but yeah.
I'm gonna give you the instructions
and give you some additional information.
Yeah. 'Cause I was
talking to Lando about it.
I was like, what do we
do with this bucket?
Cause my chief question was
do they pick it up every
week and dump it out?
I'm gonna tell you.
And is this a different truck?
If you let me tell you.
Like the taxes going into this.
I'm gonna tell you.
I mean this is.
I think this represents progress.
I think this is a good thing.
So I feel positive about it.
I feel good about it.
I don't know how to feel about it.
And I'm gonna tell you in a second
why I don't know how to feel about it.
But you're right that it
has to do with methane
Or meethane if you're British.
I am not.
And it has to do with the fact that
methane is a greenhouse gas.
They gotta make it all about them
Is a greenhouse gas that
while there's not nearly
as much methane released
on a daily basis, it is much
more of a greenhouse gas.
The magnitude per like
metric ton of methane.
The impact in terms of
greenhouse gas is much higher.
So it takes a little
bit of methane to make
a lot of bad stuff happen.
Okay. Compared to.
Compared to CO2.
I was also thinking why is this the thing
that they're talking about?
And again, I am an environmentalist
and I believe in the.
I believe in the science behind
global warming, climate change.
And I think we gotta start, you know.
We should have a long time
ago started doing things.
So I believe in this in theory.
I'll tell you why I'm
questioning it in a little bit.
But what you do is you
put your food waste.
And it has a list of
acceptable food waste.
Liquids are not included
in the food waste.
Like you can't put liquid
in there and you can't
pour your milk in there and you can't
put your grease in
there. So we're talking.
Right
Like actual organic food waste.
Banana peels, eggshells are
the two things Lando told me.
I don't know about meat
and bones, but I doubt.
I doubt you can put that in there.
It's all on the thing.
But what you do is you take a plastic bag.
And it said you can use any plastic bag.
Including the ones that you
get from the grocery store.
Okay.
And you put, you line the bag with a.
You line the bucket with a plastic bag.
Then you take that you tie it up
and you throw that whole
plastic bag into your green bin.
What?
Your yard waste bin.
Yard waste bin.
And so Jesse and I were
talking about this.
So we have we have three
bins just so you know.
We got a black bin.
That's the naughty trash.
We've got the blue bin,
which is the recyclables.
Turns out there's a lot of
you can't put in there
that you thought you could.
And then now there's this
little bucket that is
a temporary container for
a bag that holds food waste
that goes into your green yard waste bag.
Yeah. So like.
With leaves and limbs and shit.
If you cut a bush up on your property
and you put those limbs in there.
Yeah.
It goes in there with
those. So this leads to.
This leads to a question.
What?
Which Jesse asked, she's like
"Well that's a really
messy job for somebody".
So somebody is sitting
somewhere with a plastic bag
which is plastic bad.
We know plastic is bad right?
Now I will, Every couple of
trips to the grocery store
ask for plastic bags because I use
those plastic bags for things at home.
Mhmm.
You know, like if I'm traveling
which I have a tendency to do.
I take my kit we call
it. Like toiletries bag.
We call my dad called it a kit.
So that's what I ended up calling it.
Okay.
And I put that because it
has some liquids in there.
I put that inside of a plastic bag and.
A second layer of safety.
Because of what happened to your clothes.
Yeah.
When we were visiting
Chicago like 15 years ago
because I had a very, very
greasy pomade. Murray's pomade.
And we decided to combine suitcases.
Like somehow it got put in my suitcase.
Yeah.
And it exploded all over my stuff, man.
Let me just say that the
idea to pack one suitcase
was probably Mr. Frugal's
idea. That was not my idea.
Yeah. Yeah.
But the idea to bring the Murray's pomade
and the idea to put the
Murray's pomade in my hair.
It's not necessarily
made for my type of hair
but I wore it for many years.
It like melted and spilled out.
'Cause it's not a screw top.
And it leaked onto how
many of your shirts?
Like a lot of stuff.
Everything I was wearing, man,
Everything I brought. Give or take.
So I'm sorry about that if
I haven't apologized before.
You probably didn't.
But that is why. I think
I did. That is why.
And I might accept your apology one day.
I put things in a plastic bag.
And I do other things with plastic bags.
But so somebody is sitting
at the center where the
yard waste comes and every
day up until before this thing
they just been like, okay,
yeah. Leaves and stuff.
And every once, you know,
somebody's doing some dumb .
Every once in a while the
guys who are collecting
the yard waste are like,
ah somebody put one of them
poop bags in here from the.
Oh, from the dog.
Somebody on a walk, you know?
Okay. That's the thing. That's helping me
make sense of this because
they're already doing the work.
'Cause first of all,
they take the green bin
and just like the blue and the black ones
a specified truck comes by picks it up
and dumps it all into the truck.
So it's not like someone
walks up to and takes
starts picking at it right
there in front of your house.
It's just like every other truck.
And when it gets to the facility
yes, somebody is already picking through
the yard waste stuff to get out the stuff
that shouldn't have been in there.
So now they're gonna be a lot busier.
They're getting these bags and
then what are they doing with these bags?
And then who's the next
person who gets the bags?
And they get bags that are
just full of rotten food?
Yeah.
And then, now we've got this
which leads me into the next thing
which is the reason that I
think this might be a scam.
It's not a scam.
Is what do you do with
those dirty plastic bags
that got stuff all in them?
Because what I've been told.
You can't recycle dirty plastic.
And now we're just putting
a bunch of dirty plastic
into the green bin?
Tell me what I'm missing.
We need to take a tour.
Because I was also told that they're
not actually recycling stuff anymore.
Yeah. They just ship it to
China and then China buries it.
They're like, "Oh yeah
this makes you feel good."
Now again.
We don't know.
I am saying I want them to recycle.
I think they should be recycling.
I'm gonna choose to recycle.
I'm gonna choose to follow the system.
But I have my doubts that the
system is actually doing the
thing that the system promised to do.
Well it's experimental.
So what do you? Like, okay.
I've gotta look this up.
I'm gonna look this up.
What do you do with peanut butter?
Compost bucket.
If you get done with a peanut butter
do you lick inside of it out?
Do you put your peanut butter
in the dishwasher thereby
using energy to get the
remnants of peanut butter out?
Yeah, I've washed it out.
You washed out the inside of
a peanut butter before you
put it in the recycling?
A few times. And that was in the.
With what? Hot water?
Hot water and soap because Lando
did a whole presentation about this stuff.
He's the one who knows about recycling.
When your kids start doing school stuff.
Yeah.
Then you start feeling
guilty about everything.
Well he came home and
was like the enforcer.
Well you gotta have
one in every household.
Yeah. He got on me
about the peanut butter.
"You can't recycle this unless
it's totally clean dad".
So I started cleaning
it. And then I was like
you know what, after doing
that twice, I was like
now I'm just throwing
it in the regular trash.
Ooh.
Because I recycle. We recycle a lot
You're a bad person.
It's just a lot of recycling
ends up in the trash anyway
is what I believed. Starting January 1st
instead of throwing that
container of fuzzy strawberries
into the trash. This is the LA Times.
A new law will require Californians to
recycle their food scraps
and other leftovers.
Said of bill 1383, mandates
that you toss organic material
into bins you use for other green waste
such as garden trimmings,
lawn trimmings, leaves.
This is part of a larger
effort to reduce short lived
climate pollutants,
including methane. Meethane?
And redirect organic waste.
Your thane.
From landfills back to the
soil as compost or mulch.
If you're unsure about how to
get started here's some tips.
Food that can be recycled.
Coffee grounds, coffee filters,
and non nylon tea bags.
Fruit and vegetable scraps,
even the moldy parts.
Eggshells, used, slash,
dirty paper food containers
Paper food containers.
Like if you get In-N-Out animal fries.
That's a paper container that's greasy.
Juice pulp, paper towels, and tissues.
What?
You can put paper towels and
tissues and paper plates.
What?
Food that can be recycled
includes paper plates.
Well I've been eating my
paper plates for years.
So that tracks.
Some cities accept more food items.
For example, Santa
Monica also accepts meat
seafood scraps and dairy products.
Check with your local municipality.
Does it say what happens to it?
I'm scrolling. What happens to it?
Now I am right about this
plastic bag part, right?.
It doesn't say what happens to it?
Brian, did you see that?
You do use the plastic bag, right?
Because that's, in my mind
we had that conversation
and Jesse was like, yes, you can use
because it said grocery bag.
Yeah. That just, that part
doesn't make sense to me
'cause why can't I just take the raw stuff
and just throw it in
there with the bushes?
I guess 'cause they don't want
the bushes to be mixed up.
What do they do with the bushes?
They're doing a different thing.
And the grass?
And if you're concerned about odors
you can layer the food with saw dust
or line it with paper towels.
Is that really gonna do it?
You can also put the container
in the fridge or freezer.
So you. So that's why
the bucket is so small.
So you can put it in your freezer?
Does it say anything
on there about the bag?
The simplest method is
putting the scraps in a
brown paper bag and
putting it in your freezer.
And then figure out where
you want that to go after.
Like the farmer's market. What?
See, we should be composting
stuff in our backyard.
But we're not doing that.
All right, so that's LA.
That doesn't say. What happens?
Doesn't say anything
about the bags, though.
What should I Google? What
happens? What happens next?
Just Google "what happens next"?
We all need to know.
California compost law.
Everything you need to know.
So alright. This should include
everything we need to know.
We need to know what happens next.
Where will all the compost go? Click.
I just wanna make sure that
I haven't complicated things
for the compost people because.
All organic waste will be
converted back soil-like
compost and used for agriculture.
Let's explore some other options
for managing your food waste.
Now this doesn't have
everything you need to know.
Yeah. That's definitely not
everything I need to know.
You know what? This is
actually an ad for Lomi.
Which is the freaking. I got tricked.
I got tricked into clicking
on the Lomi website which is.
Man, that.
And then the number one thing you can do
use an electric composter.
And then up here it says get Lomi.
Which is a sponsor on GMM.
But it ain't a sponsor here
so we're gonna move on. But
that is something you can do.
Use an electric composter.
I don't know what happens to it.
Pizza boxes cannot be recycled.
But can they now go in this compost?
They won't fit. They're
too big for the bucket.
But is cardboard a paper food container?
You can put the pizza
boxes in the blue bin.
Oh yeah, you can. You can?
But not if there's still pizza.
Long as there isn't cheese on it.
Yeah, yeah. If you're getting good pizza
it's got cheese on it, man.
I mean the cheese has
been sticking to things.
Well, Fox 11 says banana peels
chicken bones and leftover
veggies won't have a place
in California trash cans under the new
under the nation's largest mandatory
residential food waste recycling program.
Yeah. I wanna know what they do with it.
They're just telling us what to do with it
in all of this stuff.
I think they do what you
said they do with it.
They're gonna take it and they're like.
They're gonna go through it
and they're gonna make it into soil.
We've got all this organic material
that now is going to
be used in agriculture
versus just rotting in
a landfill somewhere
and giving off meethane.
I remember one time, do you remember
when we were in Asheville, North Carolina?
It may have been for Bury Me
Naturally on Commercial Kings.
Uh huh.
We met a guy and his name was like Whistle
or something like that, you know?
It was like one of those guys
that sort of just like lives
on the street of Asheville. An old guy.
Whistle.
Sort of a hippie. I don't
think it was Whistle
but it's like, he had a name like that.
He said, "How much trash do you make?"
I remember he asked that question.
"How much trash do you make?"
And I was like, I don't know. A lot.
And he was like, and he held up a bag
and it was the same size as the pail
that you've already described.
Yeah.
10 by 10, probably 14 inches tall.
He's like, 'This is all the
trash I generate in a year."
And he just holds it for a year?
I think he was about to throw it away.
Wow. He caught him at a perfect time.
It's been one year. So
he was making a point.
But I will say, I think about this often.
Okay. So this is the part
of this that bothers me.
And I think the reason that
this conversation kind of like
it makes me feel
uncomfortable because I mean
there have been times,
a few times actually
where we might, you
know, we have people over
for parties or whatever. Game night.
And you feed people and you
all of a sudden you generated
more trash than you typically
would as a family in those weeks.
Yeah.
Sometimes we can barely. One week.
Seven days of four
people living in America.
Plus their friends living it up
at their house a little bit.
Yep, yep.
Fills up the entire trash can.
Oh yeah.
And then the recycling sometimes
is filled up and sometimes
I'll be like, okay
we're gonna have to just put this in a bag
and hope they also take
it 'cause it won't fit.
Or we'll put it in a bag and leave it
next to the trash can or leave it up there
and then they'll take it and then we'll
put it, you know, we'll
overflow into the next week.
Right.
My point is, it's clear
if you just do the math, right?
This is totally unsustainable.
So much trash.
That just a little family of four
is making that much trash in a week
when Whistle is over there in Asheville
making this little bag.
And then of course, if you
start, if you compare what
the waste that we're generating
to a developing country
it's gonna be a whole lot less per capita.
Like if everyone was living
the way that we were living
it would just be absolute mayhem.
But it kind of is mayhem.
Have you been to a landfill?
Yeah, I did.
It stinks.
Well, should we just dig a hole?
Yeah.
We just dig a hole. We keep digging a hole
and throwing stuff in it.
And I, me and my family, we're adding
trash that weighs more
than all of us put together
every single week.
I mean, I, I'm, every.
I can't defend myself.
It's like, how do you do
that? What do you say?
I mean, I'm filling up my
recycle bin every week.
I'm putting on my boots and I'm getting.
I'm climbing up in it
and jumping up and down
to get as much into the
recycling as possible.
Like I couldn't recycle more
unless I got a second bin.
Which I guess I could do.
But now I'm gonna do
this food waste thing.
And by the way. This
is still the Fox site.
They're talking about somebody in Davis.
Davis, California already has
a mandatory food recycle program
and Joy, a mother of three
puts all of her cooking
scraps into a metal bin
labeled compost on her countertop.
When preparing dinner
she empties excess food
from the cutting board
into the bin, et cetera.
After a few days she dumps the contents
into her green waste bin outside that is
picked up and sent to a county facility.
Unpleasant countertop bin
smells haven't been a problem.
All you're changing is where
you're throwing things away.
It's just another bin. It's really easy.
And it's amazing how much
less trash you have. Hmm.
I mean the thing about throwing away trash
is that when you get
that food stuff in there
boy, that stuff starts
to ooze out and you might
you get animals showing up. You know?
Yeah. I've had my trashcan knocked over
Decimated.
Four or five times since
I moved to where I'm at.
Raccoons
By something. I think it
might be a team of raccoons
in a trench coat. Because I don't know
how they get the damn trash can over.
But it seems like they're
not putting it in a bag.
In Davis at least she's dumping.
Yeah. Yeah. I gotta reread it.
She dumps the contents directly
into the green waste bin
along with all of the other stuff.
So the plastic bag thing is, I don't know.
It feels like it might be wrong.
That may be your misunderstanding.
Well, you know, I'm gonna say my wife
was the one reading it
so I'm gonna blame her.
But I'm gonna read it tonight.
We almost perpetuated it.
We'll do another. We're
gonna do another question
after we talk a little bit
about Good Mythical Evening.
Good Mythical Evening is September 1st.
It is an R rated live event.
Watch it as it happens as we go full R.
Exclusively on Moment House.
Yeah, it is.
I'm telling you, you
should be there for it.
I have promised
I'm gonna be there.
That I think we all know.
We've talked about the fact
that Link took us all a little
off guard last year with getting
a little too intoxicated.
And I was like, do I need
to hold down the fort?
And I made the decision
to hold down the fort.
And Stevie was very thankful
and let me know that.
But I've let Stevie know that
she is the only person who
will be holding down the fort this year.
So, you know, I think
the question is gonna be
are you going to try to outdo yourself?
Because there could be a line
that you don't need to cross.
Are you gonna try to outdo
yourself or am I gonna just meet
you at the place that you were?
Are you gonna try to separate yourself?
It could get a little tricky
if that's your mentality.
Especially if you got those glasses on.
Wouldn't you like to know?
But there's only one way to
find out and that's to watch
Good Mythical Evening when it happens.
Goodmythicalevening.com.
You got to buy a ticket.
We talked enough about
recycling and stuff.
Composting. We've talked
too much about it.
I believe in it. I'm just gonna say
it stresses me out, man.
We're blazing a trail.
There's still plenty of places on earth
and in America in many counties
that they don't recycle
and there's no recycling bins.
Well, there's plenty of places.
If you see one of those videos where
it's a literal river of plastic trash
that's probably not the US.
I'm just gonna say it's
probably not the US.
The US has got a lot of problems
and the US is generating
a lot of these problems.
But we don't have just
rivers of plastic crap.
That hasn't happened yet.
But anyway, we just gotta
stop making that stuff.
I think that's the thing
that's frustrating is that
the way that we talk about
this is we talk about
personal responsibility and we want
every individual to do what they
do their part, which I believe in.
But when you are faced with a
system where every single time
you go to the grocery
store 95% of the things
that you're gonna buy are gonna come
in something that then creates trash.
Every time you go out to eat,
you're gonna create trash.
Like there's larger systemic
issues that you can't
just wait for every individual
to make the right decisions.
Like we have to have systemic
change so that we all don't.
You can't just rely on
people to make all kinds of
good decisions because people are gonna do
what the easy thing is, man.
People aren't gonna wash their
freaking peanut butter out.
It's a, yeah. I think you.
Unless your kid does a
project and they do it twice.
It's a both, and. I'm willing to accept
increasing responsibility and education.
As long as it happens on other levels.
Conversationstarters.com, not a sponsor.
Yet.
Hit it.
What's the longest you've
gone without sleep?
What is the? Okay. All right.
Okay conversationstarters.com. Oh man.
What's the longest you've gone?
The AI heard us talking
about it and was like, okay
try this one on first size, boys.
I mean, I definitely
am on record saying that
I never elected to pull
an all nighter in college.
Which is the first place
I think that you're gonna
be apt to stay up all night.
Except for that one time that we went
snowboarding in the mountains and.
That's a good place to snowboard.
And we. Yeah, it is. We went. So we had a.
As opposed to the plains.
We had to drive a number of hours.
You start skiing at like 1:00 AM.
The night ski at Hawks nest, same place.
This was the the scenario
under which I broke my pelvis
and suffered the concussion.
But I remember at a
preceding time, we did it.
You start skiing at 1. You ski from like
1 to maybe, like 1 to 4.
Does that sound right to you?
Night skiing.
Night skiing. They got the lights on.
I don't believe you're right about that.
You think it's done by 1?
My best guess is that.
It might be done by 1.
Because first of all during the winter
sunset is probably 5:30 or 6.
Yeah.
So I think it's probably
like 6 to midnight.
Night skiing.
Yeah. And then I think, I
think you might could go to 1
and then it's kind of over.
'Cause they gotta make snow at some point.
And then we had to drive back
and maybe stopping at the
Waffle House and all that
stuff. By the time I got back
I did not sleep. I went straight to class.
And I just remember being
in my medieval history class
and I could not stay awake.
And I was taking notes and I literally
was able to look back at my notes
and see the moment that
I fell asleep because.
Like a movie it just
became a squiggly line.
Yeah. It's just like a, yeah.
The line just kind of squiggled
down off the page and.
That's how I want to die.
I was fighting. I was fighting so hard.
Taking notes.
You know, you just cannot
stay awake any longer.
That was. So I remember
that being an all-nighter.
I don't recall that.
I mean the most recent
all-nighter was when we shot Hazel
and we were fighting
against the sun coming up.
That's right.
So this is, in case you didn't know
this is the TikTok first.
We released it on TikTok
and then we put it on the
Rhett and Link YouTube channel.
But basically our horror, you know
spending a night in the
creative house kind of thing.
Nobody watched it.
But if you were there
for it when it happened.
It was awesome.
You were thrilled by it. Which is great.
We, obviously we stayed up all day
'cause that's typically what we do.
'Cause I'm not a vampire
and I also don't take naps.
But then the night shoot
rolled around and you know
Ben had the shot list planned.
Soon as it gets dark we start
'cause we gotta shoot in the dark.
We had talked about
potentially like doing blackout
of the windows but we
were trying to avoid that
because it takes a bunch of time.
Yeah. So it was, we had
one night in the woods.
Which did not take all night.
And then the next night I
believe is when we went back to
the creative house and we were shooting
all night in the house. And that's the one
that went all the way til the sun came up.
Yeah so we actually kind
of going on less sleep.
I just remember the sun coming up.
And that was when we were
packing everything up
and putting it back in the trucks and
being very tired, but not being sleepy.
My body was like, okay, well
we missed that opportunity.
And then I was like, I'm
gonna go home. I don't.
Miss that opportunity what?
To sleep
To sleep.
But now circadian rhythm is in play
and your body's like,
okay, well now it's okay.
I guess another day is here.
And I have such a difficult
time sleeping during the day.
I know I had to have. I don't remember it
but I had to have slept. You
didn't sleep during the day?
No, no. I went home and
slept for I think probably
two hours and then woke up and was like
I guess I'll just, you know,
I'll never make up for this.
I don't think I've ever
done more than that.
What I've never done.
'Cause obviously we did the
same thing with all night long.
All night long when we sang
Lionel Richie's All Night Long
literally for 11 hours. All
night long. It's on YouTube.
Check it out. Check it out, Brian.
You didn't know about that.
That was from sundown to sunrise.
And then again, same thing,
like go home, go to sleep.
That was easy because we were constantly
Engaged.
Occupied. And there were certain scenes
with the Hazel thing,
especially towards the morning.
Like they were shooting something with you
and then I had this downtime.
And once you sit down and you get still
that gets difficult.
We had one all-nighter
for Buddy System, too.
Well, Buddy System
also. It was season one.
So yeah, we've had a few all-nighters, but
neither one of us have ever
been the type of person to say
let's just stay up all
night and I can do that.
You know, there's people who can do that.
Okay.
I mean, I get. When I get really tired
I start to feel like nauseous.
It's like my body just
starts shutting down.
Well, I'm about to scare you a little bit.
You're about to tell me
it's actually a good thing.
You should be doing it on a monthly basis.
No, no, no. Well, I read
that book Why We Sleep
which then I found out that
at least some of the research
that the guy had quoted
in it was not right.
And so I don't know what part
that was. I didn't follow up.
Okay.
But one of the things he talks about is
you basically don't make up for it.
Like you can't, you don't
make up for lost sleep.
Whatever the effects of
missing sleep have, it's
you get those effects
and they're short term.
And then of course compounding
there's long term effects.
And like, one of the
things he talks about is
people who are chronically under sleeping.
Like you hear people like Steve Harvey
he's one of 'em who will say like
"I sleep four hours a day".
Yeah.
Jay Leno says the same thing.
And there's this pride of
you only sleep four hours.
And this guy's point was that yes there is
a range of what people
require but really nobody
can get away with that little sleep.
They're suffering. They're
suffering consequences
that are long-term health consequences.
So when Steve Harvey's
mustache just falls off one day
it's probably 'cause he's only
getting four hours of sleep.
That's how it happens, huh?
It starts with a mustache.
Now there's been a
couple of times, you know
I told you earlier in the
year when I started struggling
a little bit with insomnia and then
I think I figured out
that it had to do with
the intermittent fasting
thing I was doing.
And that's a kind of a common side effect
but it didn't go away for me.
But because I'm a hypochondriac
or I have whatever, health anxiety
whatever the proper term is today.
Okay.
There was a point in which I was waking up
and not being able to go back to sleep.
And I thought that I might
have fatal familial insomnia.
What? Fatal familial?
It's a rare genetic
degenerative brain disorder.
Like you can't sleep and
it kills a family member?
It is. Well, that can happen.
It is characterized by an
inability sleep. Insomnia.
That may be initially mild
but progressively worsens
leading to significant physical
and mental deterioration.
Affected individuals may
also develop dysfunction
of the auto autonomic nervous system.
The part of the nervous
system that controls
involuntary automatic body processes.
Well, yeah, but.
Basically.
Why do you think you have it?
I don't have it.
You just got scared.
I wasn't sleeping.
I mean, it is a form of torture.
I would hate. I hate it for
the people who can't sleep.
Like that's, it's just.
You're not technically.
It is literally a form of torture
But you're not listening to me.
I'm listening to you.
I'm not talking about
somebody who can't sleep.
I'm talking about a disease
in which you slowly lose
the ability to sleep and invariably die.
Gosh.
You're not listening to
what I'm saying, bro.
I'm not talking about insomnia.
I'm talking about chronic insomnia
that they do not have a cure for.
And it happens to some people
and they just freaking die.
So you stay awake to death?
Yes!
Well, I heard you eventually.
Man, that is a nightmare.
And I've, you know, I hate to make.
I'm not making light of it
'cause I thought I had it
but somebody does, somebody does have it.
They don't know what to do about it.
They can't do anything about it.
There's no treatment for it.
You can. I mean there's gotta be like
some high powered
something to knock you out.
I don't think so. I think that you you're.
Whatever is in your brain
that allows you to sleep.
Oh gosh.
Eventually just goes away.
But what's how long can you go
without sleep before you die?
That's another question.
Yeah.
I'm not getting that one from
conversationstarters.com.
I got that one from my brain.
How long can you stay awake without dying?
'Cause you can go a few
days without water. Right?
Yeah I think.
You can go a few weeks without food.
If you're not sleeping
you need to stay hydrated.
You need to eat
11 days.
Yes. The longest recorded
time without sleep
is approximately 264 hours or
just over 11 consecutive days.
What?
Now that person just probably fell asleep.
I don't know if they died.
Hmm. And there's like, you know
you'll have like mind or
body altering drugs that will
keep you awake in order to get
stuff done beyond caffeine.
Stuff I don't even wanna know about.
I mean, I love sleeping.
There's times when I get in
the bed and I'm just like.
I'll just be so happy that I'm
in my bed, I'll just squeal.
Yeah! I'll just like wiggle up
in there and just get snugly.
But now that, these dogs.
Like we got Jasper and Jade in
the bed and they're freaking.
They move around and you
know, we got these aura rings
that track all of our movement and give me
a sleep score every morning.
And it's very helpful information.
And I hate to say it
but it's made me think
that like the dogs don't
need to stay in the bed.
You know? Because
whenever they move around
it makes me move my hand
that has my ring on it.
And then my sleep score lowers.
I don't know if I'm actually waking up.
What is the nature? Where do they sleep
in relation to you and
Christy? And is it consistent?
Jade sleeps on my right side
in between my arm and my hip.
Facing, her nose faces down
and her butt faces my armpit.
So I kind of like have my arm over her.
'Cause you sleep on your back
'cause you got a special pillow.
Yeah. I sleep on my back 'cause
it's the superior way to sleep.
So I've trained myself to do
it with my very uncomfortable.
Brick of a pillow.
Cylinder pillow. And then Jasper will
he'll burrow down to the bottom.
And then in the middle of the night
we'll just hear him whimpering down there.
He doesn't know how to get out.
Suffocating.
No he is not suffocating.
He just, I mean dachshunds
are like burrowing dogs.
They love to burrow down.
But then he wants to get
out and then I'll have to
wake up enough to lift the
covers and then he sees the exit.
Jade never had this problem
when she was younger.
Well, Jasper's probably dumber. It's cool.
And then, uh, I think Jasper's smarter.
He's just dumb in this area.
Dumb in this area. And
then he will climb up
and he will go and he will
lay above Christy's head.
Which can't be good for her sleep.
If she was sitting up
and he was still in the same place
it would be like she was
wearing Jasper like a hat.
This happens every night?
Every other night he usually gets up there
and perches as a hat on her head.
Yeah, so that kind of is
disturbing our quality of sleep.
It's more of a Jasper
thing than a Jade thing.
But then every four nights
Jade will get up out of the bed
and she's thirsty.
Oh yeah. She's a Neal.
She wants some water. And so
I got a little mug of water
I put in the bathroom but she
won't walk in the bathroom
get it and just jump back in bed.
She'll get out of the bed
and she'll shake her head and
flop flop flop flop flop
her ears to wake me up
so that I will escort her to the bathroom.
This is obviously dysfunctional.
Why don't you put the
water bowl next to the bed?
I don't know. I don't know.
It feels like that problem can be solved.
That's a good idea, Rhett?
Like why does the water bowl
have to be in the bathroom?
Just put a little water
bowl next to the nightstand
on the side that she comes off of.
And it could be a dog bowl
instead of a human cup
that I used to use when I brush my teeth.
Yeah.
We're not really thinking strategically.
It's just a dog bowl and then she can also
probably get a little swig
right before she goes to bed.
You know how you go
months without thinking
you have a problem and you just don't stop
and think strategically about it?
Thank you for bringing
me out of my stupor.
That's why we do this.
I mean it's kind of like parents who
sleep with their baby in the bed.
And then next thing you know
their baby's six years
old and still in the bed.
Alicia Silverstone.
You know, it's like, I mean, you got.
Her kid is.
At a certain point, who's in charge here?
Her kid's 11.
Now. Yeah. You get.
Why don't you say some?
You got 11 year old in the bed.
No, no. Why don't you dig
yourself a little hole?
Let's talk about Alicia
Silverstone and her child
who's 11 sleeping in the bed with her
and dig yourself a little hole.
That's what we're here for.
I just feel like you've
got. I'm guilty of it.
You're. You.
No. Well, I've never done that.
I'm guilty of it with the
dog. With the cup thing.
So I'm not above reproach here.
But there's a certain
point when you have to
come to your senses and
say, "who's in charge here"?
Who's the parent and who's the puppy?
Who's the, who's the?
We're talking about children not puppies.
Who's clueless, and who's
an 11 year old human?
Yeah. It's like.
I thought her.
At a certain point they
gotta be in their own bed.
Okay. Tell that to all
the parts of the world
in which there's a family
bed that they all sleep in.
Oh God, Rhett. Why? Why
are you doing this to me?
'Cause I'm just showing you.
'Cause I think the same way as you.
When I heard about Alicia
Silverstone's child
sleeping in the bed with her at 11
I was like, well that kid's
gonna have X, Y, and Z.
It's never gonna be able
to let go of the mom.
I didn't say any of that. I just said
at a certain point, you need to sleep.
But I'm just as guilty of it with a dog.
No, but.
Two dogs.
But it was interesting. And
I don't think she made this.
She didn't care. She doesn't care.
She obviously doesn't care. She's been.
There's been a number of things
Alicia Silverstone has done
in relationship to her child.
I like, the first thing
was like, she did a.
She was the mama bird feeder of the child.
Like chewing the food and giving the food.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think. Don't quote me on that.
But I think that was the first sort of
controversial thing and
unconventional thing.
And then it was the 11 year old.
It was the most recent thing.
Of course, if she would've
been in Buddy System
as was discussed for a brief moment.
Oh yeah.
We wouldn't be having
this conversation now
because she would be friends
and we would totally understand.
I'm defending her.
We'd be on her side.
What I'm saying. She didn't really
defend herself 'cause she doesn't care to.
But in the article I was reading about it
somebody was talking about the fact that
there's really no evidence
that this is going to cause
any particular problems with the child.
The only thing you really
wanna avoid is you definitely
don't want your.
Just having your own life.
I mean sleep means so much
to me that it's just like
the kid will be okay in another room.
I mean there's exceptions to every rule
but like in general. C'mon.
I'm talking about the kid for a second.
So yes. I'm not gonna let my
kids sleep with me in my bed.
Yeah. 'Cause I want to be in
my own bed and I wanna sleep.
But if you're thinking about
it from their perspective
what you really don't wanna do
is you don't wanna have like
a newborn baby in the bed because
that's where you roll over
and you kill the baby. I
mean that happens. Right?
That's horrible.
Some people don't know
what's going on and stuff.
Yeah.
But yeah, to me, it's just like
it's more of a convenience thing.
But the point that these
psychologists were making is
that, no, it's actually not.
It doesn't necessarily mean
that this kid's gonna have
attachment issues. We don't know that.
But we don't have reason to think so.
And also this is the way that many humans
have slept together for many, many years.
There was a family. Still
in many places in the world.
There's like a family
bed. There's a place.
There's a room that everybody sleeps in.
It's like a den of
everybody sleeping together.
So, and I guess if you want to
if you're mom and dad, or
mom and mom, and dad and dad
and you want to have a little hanky-panky.
Yeah. What about the hanky-panky?
I think you go to a different place.
Go to the kid's room?
They don't don't have a room.
You go to the kitchen I guess.
While everybody's sleeping
you go to the living room.
Like that couple that was
having sex in the living room
that we were talking about last time.
Oh yeah. Okay.
Or a couple times ago. Whenever that was.
Yeah.
First let me just, back to sleeping.
For a science fair project in 1965
Randy Gardner set the world record.
A kid?
By going 264 hours
roughly 11 days, without
sleep. Now, first of all.
How old was?
I don't know who this Randy. If he.
I mean, he wasn't more than
a high schooler probably.
I mean Randy Gardner? Science fair?
Do people do science? In
the sixties were there
adults doing science fair projects?
'Cause I don't know enough about this.
But the sixties seems like
the last decade in which
a eighth grader could
be making this decision.
And everybody's like, well,
"Randy. You hear about Randy?
Yeah. The Gardner boy. He's
been up for nine days."
You know, nobody's worried
about whether he is gonna die.
They're just getting ready to do a parade.
You know in the sixties it was still like
the last decade that you could really let
Randy go 11 days without
sleeping. Is he gonna die?
"We don't know if he's gonna
die, but you know what?"
"He's not gonna die".
"He's doing this for the town".
"He's doing it for the blue ribbon".
"He's putting the school on the map".
Randy Gardner.
This resulted in significant.
This is risescience.com.
Also not a sponsor.
What happened?
But the.
What happened to Randy Gardner?
I would just say, the web
design on rise science
is better than conversation starters.
Meh. My two cents.
Okay.
This resulted in significant declines in
his concentration, motivation, perception
and higher level mental processes.
All part of the experiment.
A 2017 NPR interview with Gardner.
Yes.
Revealed signs of nausea.
On the third morning?
That's a weird way to put that.
You mean this many years
later revealed signs of?
You mean Randy told you that
he was sick on the third day?
That's just a weird way to write it.
On the third day of sleeplessness
I got a little bit sick.
Randy Gardner got a little nauseous.
But I knew I needed to win.
Most worryingly, he
complained of memory loss
which he felt like an early
Alzheimer's thing brought on
by lack of sleep.
An early Alzheimer's thing?
Well, you know.
Oh.
He's not a scientist.
He's a kid who did a science project.
In other words, the human body isn't made
to withstand sleep
deprivation to any degree.
I did a science project where I was
talking about the environmental
thing from the top
of this conversation where
we buried toilet tissue.
Different types of toilet paper.
And we saw the rate that
it would biodegrade.
Over the course of like
a couple of months.
Like none of them biodegraded at all.
It was kind of a, it was
kind of a short lived.
So what did you conclude?
Don't bury your toilet paper.
Hold on. Randy is still alive.
Of course he is
He lives in San Diego.
How's he doing now? How's his nausea?
He's an American from
San Diego, California.
Okay wiki.
Set the record for the
longest amount of time
a human has gone without sleep.
In December '63.
I don't think Guinness allows this record.
They don't certify it
anymore because it does harm.
You know?
Yeah yeah yeah.
So I don't think they
certify this type of record.
17 year old Gardner stayed awake
for 11 days and 25 minutes,
breaking the previous record
of 260 hours by Tom Rounds?
I don't, don't go. I don't
wanna hear about Tom.
No.
He's a loser.
Oh, Tom.
He's clicking on Tom.
Wikipedia is trying to get me to donate.
I'll do that on my own time, okay?
Mm.
Ooh. Tom Rounds was.
Means he's dead. He died in 2014.
Was an American radio
broadcasting executive.
Founder and chief executive officer
of Radio Express in Burbank, California.
Okay.
These people who staying up for. Hey man.
We might be next on the list.
These people who aren't
sleeping are in California.
Southern California. Both of them.
Yep.
Tom Rounds and Randy Gardner.
What about Rhett McLaughlin and Link Neal?
I think it would be a funny video
for us to see how long we could stay up.
Because it, but it only gets like
you only need to show
the last hour. You know?
'Cause like that dozing
off thing that you just do.
That would be funny.
Yeah. I think we could do
something with that as a stunt.
How long do you think you could stay up?
Longer than you.
Definitely longer. But like
you can't, like. No caffeine.
You can't have any substances
to aid in your staying awake.
It feels like it could be
boring. I mean, this is what.
Yeah. It's edited.
This is what Mr Rounds did.
Tom, while in Hawaii, he,
hoping to gain publicity
for his new position as a disc jockey
Mhmm.
Set the world record for sleeplessness.
The period of 260 hours awake
was attained while Rounds
was sitting in a department store window.
This is awesome.
Publicity stunt. Now I am remembering
back in the burgeoning
days of live streaming.
Shay Carl and Charles Trippy
ever the innovators of the time.
Probably 2008.
Mhmm.
Maybe 2007. They did a 24/7 broadcast
of them staying awake.
24 hours.
No, as long as they could go to see who
could go the longest between
the two of 'em. Remember that?
Ah, I think remember this.
Cause I watched some of it.
Okay. I'm gonna look that up.
I don't know who went longest.
Charles Trippy, Shay Carl.
We were down there in Lillington.
Not sleeping.
It looks like there aren't
many good matches for your search.
I definitely remember this happening.
It was like a Justin TV.
I mean, Twitch didn't exist.
You know, Ustream type thing.
I can't find how long they went. But.
That's sad that it's not
anywhere on the internet.
Randy did eventually recover.
And according to news
reports Gardner's record
has been broken a number of times.
But there's no official
certification of it.
I, you know, I take it back.
I don't want to have
anything to do with this.
Sleep is way too precious
for me. You know? It's just.
It's like time travel.
That's what I always say.
One minute you're in one day.
Next minute you're in the next day.
That means you slept well though.
If it feels like it like
you know, anesthesia.
The Australian National
Sleep Research Project
which is my favorite Australian
national sleep research project.
Okay.
States the record for sleep deprivation is
18 days, 21 hours, and 40 minutes.
So that's another seven days.
Wow.
Almost another nine days.
That is torture. I mean that is torture.
It's not gonna happen to me.
But sleeping.
I'm just like, I'm hoping
it doesn't happen to me.
I think that.
I don't wanna lose my mustache.
I think that the thing that
I've been focusing on lately
and I do think that it has a lot to do
with us getting these rings.
And also before that, like
when I would wear that.
I was wearing the apple watch and this
and then it was kinda like,
oh, I got two smart things.
Oh, you're kind of still doing it.
Yeah. I'm doing two smart things.
But I can only do one
smart thing at a time.
But it makes you more conscious of it.
And I have to. I'm the
advocate for sleep in my home.
Now this is where I think that
I have a little bit more of,
some challenges built in.
Because my impression is that
Christy will fall asleep
before you sometimes.
Yeah. I mean, she's still in summer mode.
She's staying up a little
later now for some reason.
What's she do in the summer?
She has a mint julep at night?
What happens? What do you mean?
She just stays up later.
For the summer?
For the summer. Yeah.
Because of the light. 'Cause of the light?
I think, coming back from vacation
and the kids still outta
school she's still like
kind of with the kids in
terms of staying up later.
But I'm not. I'm back working it.
My wife never goes to sleep before me.
And I have to have these
little sessions where I'm like
Hey, you know? Can we try to
go to bed before midnight?
And she's like, you can go
to bed whenever you want to.
And I'm like, yeah, but
I'm a light sleeper and.
Oh.
I don't. I can try to go
to sleep before you do.
But like you getting in the
bed is gonna wake me up.
Like, can we go to bed? Go to bed earlier?
And you know, I'm making slow progress.
But the other thing I was
thinking about the other day was
one of the. I follow a
few different sort of like
doctor accounts. Like doctor influencers.
Like Rhonda Patrick and Andrew Huberman.
Okay.
Who, I think they both
have their own podcast but.
Who doesn't?
They have podcasts where
there's legit information that
is given. Not just two
guys with a laptop. And.
Who are these two guys? They sound cool.
But the one thing that she
was saying the other day
was she does a thing on her Instagram
where she will be like,
here's the latest study
about this thing and
I'm gonna summarize it
and tell you what you
need to know about this.
Okay.
And it was a study of 6 to 12 year olds
and how, basically, 6 to 12 year olds
need to get a minimum of 9 hours of sleep.
Preferably 9 to 12 hours.
Wow.
And if they don't get at
least 9 hours of sleep
this study shows that they
end up with memory issues
attention deficit issues,
impulse control issues.
Basically the things that
you kind of think about
when you think about teens.
But some of these things
may be diagnosable as well.
And I was just thinking two things.
Number one. It's too late for
my kids. You know, it's like.
Too late for my kids.
You know, because it's very
difficult to get Shepherd
to have a sleep schedule. He
won't go to bed on his own.
You eventually, like, sometime
during the pandemic you know?
Yeah.
We eventually just kind of gave up on it.
We'd fight sometimes. We'd go
down the middle of the night.
We'd find him like on the
computer playing video games
at like 3:00 AM. And we
would discipline him.
We would change. You do all
the things to try to stop it.
But he hasn't gotten consistent sleep.
Now that he's like a teenager,
at least during the summer
he's sleeping late. So maybe
he's ended up, ends up getting.
I don't know. But the thing I was thinking
in addition to, well, it's too
late for me and my kids, was
we live in a really
interesting time in which
we've got all this information.
We know so many things.
There's so much. So many
studies have been done.
There's still so much that we don't know.
A lot more that we don't
know that we do know.
But, if I was. I feel like
it would be different.
It's different to be. Like,
if we were the typical
LA 44 year olds who like, had a newborn.
Just think about at this stage
at this stage in my life.
Oh my gosh.
With this much more internet
having happened in my brain
and this much more access to information.
You're talking about
being a better parent?
I'm just talk. I don't.
What I'm saying is I'm kind of glad.
I'm kind of glad I'm almost done.
Yeah.
Because I didn't know about stuff.
I didn't know, like, well, they should be
doing this or they shouldn't be.
I mean, there's things that we knew.
We shouldn't have been giving
our kids cigarettes like we were.
Right, right.
I mean, that was a mistake.
And I probably could have known that.
No, but I'm talking about.
It took me while.
Screen time and all this stuff.
The lit end is on the outside.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's like I gotta figure that out.
I don't know. It's a blessing and a curse.
Because what's done is done in one sense.
Hey, what's done is done, man.
But if I was, if I had
a newborn right now?
Oh gosh. Like with all the
stuff they try to sell.
The world is so different too. And like
there's this, there's
COVID, and there's, you know
these things that you gotta, well
my God there's monkeypox, you know?
And then your kids can't be on screens
and they gotta get nine
to 12 hours of sleep
and you gotta be taking these
vitamins when you're pregnant.
It's like.
And now they gotta put their food waste
in a different bucket.
Yeah. Our kids just threw their food waste
out the car window. You
know what I'm saying?
Just going down the highway
just throwing banana
peels on the roadside.
Now they gotta put it in a bin?
I don't know. I think
I'm glad my kids are.
One's about to go off to college.
We'll talk about that
in an upcoming episode.
That's right.
I don't know exactly when
we're talking about that, but.
After it happens, probably.
He leaves very soon.
So that you can tell us about it.
All right.
And Shepherd, you know, he's coasting.
Is this a high note or a low note?
I feel like we're ending on a low note.
Steve Harvey.
I can find another question.
Still has his mustache.
Why don't, you know, listen.
We're leaving it to you
to end on a high note
because you've got a rec.
Okay.
Rec baby. Rec baby. 1, 2, 3, 4.
I recommend that, you
know, if you're at a loss
for conversation.
Oh gosh. you can't make
conversationstarters.com.
Head on over to conversationstarters.com.
What about capitalize my title?
Not a sponsor. And if you want.
If you've written something out.
If you've strung out
a whole bunch of stuff
and then you realize that, oh God.
How do I?
So many of these words
need to be capitalized.
Four of. Four.
Capitalize my title.
Four of these five words
need to be capitalized.
Dot com.
Let me go to a website to do it.
This is the dumbest thing
I've ever heard of, okay?
I'm sorry capitalizemytitle.com.
Link thinks you're a good idea.
I think the proof is in the pudding.
The reason that you made your website
All right, fine.
Into conversationstarters.com,
essentially,
You know what?
Is because you knew that
you had a dumb idea.
My rec now is pudding. Fine.
Oh.
Eat more pudding.
What flavor?
Chocolate vanilla swirl.
Okay. All right. I can get down with that.
But get it out of the recyclable thing
and make it yourself. Don't get it out.
Don't get the individual
packs. That creates more waste.
Don't forget. Get your tickets to
Good Mythical Evening at
goodmythicalevening.com.
A live ticketed event on September 1st.
If you can handle it.
Exclusively on Moment House.
And also, hashtag ear biscuits.
Let us know what you think
about the rabbit hole episode.
I mean, we have fun when we come in here
and go to conversationstarters.com.
And if you wanna weigh in
give us a little voicemail. 1-888
EARPOD1.
Bye.
[Alex on voicemail] Hey Rhett and link.
This is Alex from Colorado.
And I just finished listening
to your podcast episode
about your trip. Your college guys.
And I have to say your
assessment on Colorado fashion
is a hundred percent correct.
We are always dressed
and ready for anything.
The weather here is also very fickle
and it will change so quickly.
So we have to be ready
to adapt to the weather.
Glad you had fun. I hope you come back
and check out more of what
our beautiful state has offer.
[Woman On Voicemail] Hi Rhett and Link.
I just watched the neighbor
and roommate horror stories.
And when y'all were
talking about the bushes
I just absolutely loved Link
being the night bush boy.
I got a really good laugh
this morning. Thanks guys.
[Thomas On Voicemail]
Hi, my name is Thomas
and I am 9 years old.
And what happens when a frog parks
in an illegal parking spot?
It gets toad.
Hey, in case you missed it
we launched a new
collection over at sike.la.
Everything we release over there
all the products and apparel,
change right before your eyes.
So check it out.
And we're giving you
a discount code to use
on your first visit.
Shop sike.la. Drop in
EBMADEYOULOOK at checkout
and enjoy 10% off your whole purchase.
EB Made You Look.
To watch more Ear Biscuits
click on the playlist
on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click on
the circular icon to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.